[Zene]
üdvözlöm minden kedves nézőnket
üdvözöllek titeket a mai vendégem szabó
réka lesz és kirmer erika örvendek hogy
itt vagytok és egy nagyon izgalmas
beszélgetés előtt állunk ugyanis olyan
témákról fogunk beszélgetni ami a z
generáció a a vezetés és az anyaság a
femininnek a kérdése úgyhogy én személy
szerint alig várom hogy belevágjunk ebbe
a beszélgetésbe röviden erikáról annyit
mondanék hogy ő több évig bukarestben
tehát ott ott tanultál és több évig ott
dolgoztál corporate világba ami mély
nyomot hagyott benned úgyhogy majd
kicsit mesélj erről mindenképpen és
utána költöztél vissza cckszeredába és a
leaders for all egyesületnek az egyik
alapítója vagy és szabó réka pedig egy
világ
járta kalandor aki eleinte skóciában
tanultál pszichológiát végeztél majd
utána északírországban foglalkoztál ha
jól értettem autista gyerekekkel
foglalkoztál igen igen úgyhogy úgyhogy
kezdjük erika egy kicsit azzal hogy
mesélj a bukaresti élményeidről és hogy
hogyan jutottál ide vissza és utána
aztán átadnám réka neked is a szót
mesélj egy kicsit azokról az élményekről
és hogyan jutottál ide vissza és akkor
utána belecsapunk abba azokba a témákba
ami engem is nagyon-nagyon érdekel én én
azt tudom mondani hogy én én bukarestet
igazából tényleg az első pillanatától az
utolsó pillanatáig ö nagyon nagyon
szerettem meg a meg az abban való
életemet azt azt
egyrészt úgy gondolom hogy hogy ki is
maxoltam minden lehetőséget ami
megtalált és hogy
és hogy az az az pont pont jó volt és
hogy mondják azt hogy hogy az a jó
hogyha az embernek ha az ember nem
vágyódik vissza ühüm sem bizonyos
életszakaszaiban sem bizonyos
élettörténeteiben nem vágyódik vissza
mert akkor azok azok kerek
megélt történetek és az az én az én
bukarestem az pont ilyen hogy hogy kerek
kerek és és megélt
formáltak formáltak az egyetemi évek
formáltak a megtapasztalásaim a a a bmds
a bukaresti magyar diákszövetség mentén
rengeteg soksok barátom lett de hogy de
hogy amúgy amúgy már amikor odamentem
akkor akkor így így
tudtam hogy hogy hogy van ott helyem
mert mert mert ott volt a a barátom is
meg neki a társasága na de hogy még így
is hogy hogy
nem tudom nem kötöttem kényszer
kényszerből barátságokat hogy ezt is
megengedte bukarest meg az egyetemi évek
hogy hogy
hogy kössek barátságokat de hogy ezek
úgy mind mind
mind azért legyenek mert ühüm mert mert
egymásra talál két ember igen és
és akkor akkor hát ez a munka is a
korporét világ nem úgy talált meg hogy
hogy a listámon volt a bakancs listámon
ez soha nem volt na de hogy de hogy
megtalált és a kezdeti nehézségek
ellenére végül végül nem tudom azt
hiszem hogy inkább helyet csináltam
magamnak benne mint helyet találtam
benne mert
mert hogy nagyon nagyon sok munkám volt
abban hogy hogy
hogy hogy komfortos legyen nekem
valahol
oda oda
bejárni aztán megtaláltak fejlődési
lehetőségek kipróbálhattam magam
magam csapatvezetőként menedzserként
csapatmenedzserként aztán regionális
menedzserként és
és egyszer csak már már kérte azt amit a
amit
már kérte azt a a a a a pozíciónak a a
szintje hogy
amit már nem tudom ami már a belső
szabadságomat
hát most nem is tudom hogy
megkérdőjelezte vagy vagy vagy ez már ez
ez ez már
igen hogy hogy ez már ez már ez már úgy
szólt bele az életembe ahogy ahogy azt
éreztem hogy nem engedhetem meg hogy
beleszóljanak az életembe ez ez
konkrétan hogy nézett
ki nem volt ez nem volt ez nem volt nem
volt nem volt ennyire konkrét vagy
de hogy de hogy nyilván én amit amit
szerettem meg amiben azt gondolom hogy
hogy kezdőként ugyan meg nyilván a
kezdők vaklövéseivel de jó voltam az az
hogy az az hogy hogy kiválogatni a
csapatba a a legmegfelelőbb embereket
bentartani azokat és
motiválni és a legembert próbálóbb az az
számomra az volt amikor a
amikor amikor ugye mindegy hogy te te 30
emberből 10et tizen akárhányat kiválónak
gondolsz merthogy merthogy saját magához
képest az ember kiválóan teljesít de hát
ezt a korporé rendszereknek a a a a vagy
a korporé világnak a bónuszrendszere ezt
nem engedheti meg ühüm és akkor
belekényszerítik az embert olyan
rangsorolásokba
amik amikről tudod te menedzserként hogy
nem f tudja az illető ühüm aki aki most
ha ha minden mindenféle jó visszajelzést
meg is kap de hát ugye mégis csak a
végén van egy ítélet ühüm tehát ennek a
szemételen rendszernek volt egy
igazságtalan oldala ami am megvis igen
igen és hogy hogy hogy azzal bíztattak
hogy hát de megvan a szabadságom abban
hogy én ezt úgy mondjam el az embernek
hogy az z ő lelkének a legkevésbé árcson
ühüm na de hát van vannak lelkek és
lelkek meg meg nyilván vannak vannak
elmondások és elmondások
nem tehát hogy hogy na hogy hogy ez ez
volt az amit amit már már már nem tudtam
nem tudtam tovább vinni és és nyilván
minél megszorítóbb lett ez a rendszer és
ezzel párhuzamosan a tapasztalatomnak
köszönhetően meg a csapat bővülésének és
a toborzásoknak köszönhetően ment egyre
jobban a csapat ühüm ez egy egyre
nagyobb feszültség volt hogy
na de hogy de
hogy hogy azt nem tudom megmondani hogy
hogy hogy önerőből mikor tudtam volna
teljesen önerőből mikor tudtam
volna kiszállni mertogy merthogy közben
az történt hogy hogy gyereket vártam és
akkor már már ez ez hát ez ez
kiszakított a korporét világból volt a
és ekkor költöztem én hazavitus már
otthon volt volt az a volt az a félszem
hogy hogy a gyermeknevelési évek meg
építik az emlékeket és hogy
hogy vajon meg tud-e történni az hogy
hogy visszavágyok és ebbe a világba nem
nem ezt úgy úgy igazán autentikusan
mondom hogy hogy nem hogy lett volna
lehetőségem rá de nem ühüm réka egy
kicsit mesélsz a te utadról egészen
hazáig igen hát azt hiszem 11-es voltam
amikor úgy megfogalmazódott bennem hogy
nagyon szeretnék külföldön tanulni
nagyon jó nyelvérzékem volt úgyhogy
szerettem volna ezt kamat ztatni és
akkor még skóciában nem kellett tandíat
fizetni az eus állampolgároknak úgyhogy
olyan alapon indultam neki igazából és a
szüleim ebben nagyon támogattak hogy
hogy próbáld meg mi a legrosszabb ami
történhet nem jutsz be vagy hogyha nem
jön hogyha nem szereted akkor hazajössz
és így kerültem el
glasgowba nagyon nagyon-nagyon szerettem
azt hogy rengeteg különböző kultúra
találkozott ott ez ez az amit hiányoltam
nagyon így a középsulis éveim al a
csíszeledában hogy hogy nincsenek kult
találkoznak különböző kultúrák de ezt
ezt nagyon-nagyon szerettem skóciában
soha egy pillanatig nem éreztem azt hogy
hogy én vagyok a külföldi hogy én vagyok
az aki nem ott született mertogy annyira
egy egy olvasztó tégj volt meg meg eleve
a skótoknak a a skót embereknek a
hozzáállása egy mindig egy ilyen
végtelenül csodálatos barátságos emlékem
marad erről és mesterizni
észak-írországba mentem át belfastzt az
megint csak én nem tudtam sokat így a
vallási politikai hátteréről
észak-írországnak meg hogy hogy ott
azért milyen min a mai napig milyen
feszültségek vannak de de nagyon-nagyon
nagyon szerettem ott lenni nagyon
megtaláltam a helyem pszichológiát
tanultam ahogy mondtad és a mesterim az
gyermekkori traumapszichológia volt és
nagyon örültem annak hogy tanulhatok
ilyent közelebb hozzánk közelebb nem
tudtam ilyen lehetőségekről úgyhogy ez
is egy olyan dolog volt ami ami mindig
mindig hajtott az hogy tudjak segíteni
embereknek hogy hogy kiképezzem magam
arra hogy hogy érdemben tudjak segíteni
nekem mindig ez volt a szemem előtt nem
voltak nagy karrierterveim mint a mai
napig nincsenek nem nem ilyenekben
gondolkodtam hanem hanem mindig ebben
hogy hogyan tudnék segíteni és akkor
ezért tanultam azt amit tanultam
belfában elkezdtem a mesteri mellett
gyógypedagógusként dolgozni
részmunkaidőben az egy olyan terület
volt amire habár nem volt
szakképesítésem de nagyon megint csak ez
hogy nagyon szeretnék megtanulni
segíteni olyan gyerekeknek fiataloknak
akiknek a a az agyuk másképp működik
akik akik másképp érzékelik a világot
akik másképp kommunikálnak azt hiszem
hogy rengeteget fejlődtem ebben hogy meg
kellett tanuljak teljesen másképp
kommunikálni meg kellett értsem azt hogy
hogy mennyire más reakciók léteznek
attól tehát hogy attól teljesen
függetlenül hogy én egy bizonyos dolgot
hogy látok lehet hogy a a a másik ember
abszolút teljesen másképp ebben
rengeteget segített az hogy hogy ilyen
autisztikus gyerekekkel és fiatalokkal
dolgoztam utána elmentem egy évet
kanadába ahol egy egy nagy tábornak
voltam az egyik ifjü vezetőségi tagja ez
is egy egy hú hihetetlen lehetőség volt
olyan dolgokat csinálhattam amiket
amiket amikben azelőtt soha nem láttam
magam például csapatépítéshez
használtunk ilyen hatalmas nagy kinti
kötélpályákat meg ilyen nagy kinti
elemeket és kiképeztek engem is arra
hogy hogy ilyen magas kötélpálya
instruktor legyek hol ott abszolút nem
amúgy egy alapjáraton egy elég szorongó
meg egy ilyen nagyon föld szó szerint
szó szerint földhöz ragadt ember vagyok
igen úgyhogy úgyhogy hát az isten
kegyelme tényleg hogy ilyen helyekre is
eljutottam és megcsinált
nagyon sokat tanultam megint nemzetközi
közegben arról hogy hogy mennyire
másképp tudunk látni bizonyos dolgokat
hogy hogyan kommunikáljunk olyankor
amikor amikor teljesen más háttérből
jövünk és teljesen másak az eddigi
tapasztalataink az életben az egy az egy
kiváltságos hely volt olyan szempontból
hogy akkor találkoztam először egy
nagyon-nagyon erős mentorprogrammal
akkor találkoztam először a
tanítványozással úgy hogy hogy azt
éreztem hogy hogy nagyon fektetnek belém
nagyon-nagyon törődnek velem a szó
minden értelmében
szakmailag a szakmai fejlődésemben olyan
olyan vezetőim voltak úgy hívják a
helyet ahol voltam a táboron belül hogy
the leadership studio és a vezetői akik
a a menedzsereink voltak de hogy sokkal
inkább sokkal inkább a a a mentoraink a
lelkiive vezetőink az édesanyáink
édesapáink
hihetetlen az a hozzáállás én nem nem
tudom azóta sem megfogni de az ahogyan a
az alkalmazottaikat merthogy elsősorban
azok voltunk de mégsem mégsem ahogyan
kezelték kezeltek minket meg ahogyan
tényleg fektettek belénk meg meg
törődtek azzal hogy hogy tudjunk
fejlődni emberileg szakmailag az egy
nagyon jó megtapasztalás volt a covid
vetett véget annak hogy én ott voltam a
covid alatt a tábor sajnos bezárt és
utána talán több mint másfél évig nem is
tudott újra nyitni akkor hazajöttem
viszont még mindig nem szerettem volna
itthon maradni úgyhogy egy egy hónapon
belül visszamentem belfába visszamentem
ugyanabba a gyógypedagógusi állásb
amiben azelőtt voltam csak ezúttal
teljes munkaidőben meg több
felelősséggel az az év az nagyon-nagyon
nehéz volt sok szempontból személyes
problémáim voltak szakmai és a végére
annak azt éreztem hogy kiégtem nem tudom
hogy ez nem tudom hogy ilyen-e az amikor
mondjuk egy egy 40-50 pluszos ember
mondja azt hogy kiégett de én azt
éreztem hogy hogy kiégtem és hazajöttem
úgy hogy megint még mindig nem terveztem
itthon maradni de akkor először éreztem
azt amikor hazajöttem 2021 nyarán hogy
mi lenne hogyha itthon maradnék vagy
miért miért is akarok én annyira kifele
menni és aztán január a 2022 januárjára
szilárdult meg bennem az hogy amúgy én
én szeretek is itthon lenni nem is
vágyom már el annyira mint amennyire azt
hittem hogy elvágyom és és nekem itt
feladatom és és lehetőségeim vannak és
akkor 2022 januárja óta vagyok itthon és
2022 februárja óta dolgozom a
erikáikkkal a leadersnél szóval
feladatok és lehetőségek ezek amik itt
itt itthon tartottak igen igen annak
ellenére hogyha egy évvel azelőtt
kérdeztél volna meg biztos hogy szembe
rőgök veled és azt mondom hogy itt hát
azért na legyünk őszinték soha nem tehát
hét év hét évig voltam amit én amúgy egy
ilyen nagyon vagány dolognak találok
hogy a hét az ugye a a a bibliában
például a teljesség meg az
örökkévalóságnak a száma hét évig voltam
külföldön azalatt a hét év alatt soha
egy pillanatig nem vágytam haza és soha
nem is gondoltam úgy hogy nekem itthon
lenne a helyem de amikor lejárt az a hét
év és hazajöttem mert úgy alakult azóta
egyáltalán soha nem fordult meg a
fejemben az hogy visszaköltözzek üüm tát
hogánynak is hétfeje van általában s
aztá még levá az ember igen ez a ez a
mesei szám ez a mesei szám és nagyon
tetszett amit mondtál hogy a te
bukaresti élményedről hogy azt szokták
mondani hogy ha nem vágysz vissza akkor
van az hogy tényleg úgy megvolt hogy
abszolút én is ezt éreztem a hét év után
hogy annak ellenére hogy tényleg mindig
mehetnékem volt annak ellenére teljesen
azt érzem hogy az egy év a négy év a két
év ahogy így helyezkedtem az országokban
meg az országok közt az úgy pont úgy
volt jó megvolt a helye
igen és hogy lejárt és hogy hogy teljes
volt még úgy is hogy a hogy mondjuk
kanad tényleg azért jöttem el mert a
covid szakította félbe a munkánkat
szóval itt egy hihetetlen potenciál
erika te hazajöttél bukarestből egy
corporate világból és réka te is egy
nagyon sokat utaztál és láttál de
megkaptad a békédet és most itthon
vagytok és elkezdtetek alkotni
elkezdtetek valami olyasmit csinálni ami
számomra is nagyon szimpatikus ezért is
akartam leülni veletek beszélgetni ez a
mentorprogram amin amúgy részt vettem és
mindjárt szeretném egy kicsit
bemutassátok ezt a mentorprramot az én
szempontomból úgy nézett ki hogy egyszer
felhívtál erika hogy nem-e vállalnám el
a válaszom az volt hogy valószínűleg nem
mert mert amúgy is a az időmet nagyon be
kell osszam és hogy a feleségemmel azért
nagyon zsonglörrködünk hogy az az első a
család és a a családi kapcsolatoknak a
fenntartása és de mégis meglepetésemre a
feleségem bölcsessége ez a feminin
bölcsesség amúgy egyből azt mondta ezt
el kell vállalni én köpniel én nem
tudtam azt mondtam hogy rendben akkor
akkor elvállalom ez az én szempontomból
úgy nézett ki hogy pár olyan fiatallal
együtt kezdtünk el egy olyan projektet
megálmodni
aki tehát most egy 11 osztályosok voltak
túlnyomót többségében ugye íigen igen
tehát ez a z generáció és amúgy én ettől
a z generációtól valamennyire tartottam
az elmúlt években erről is maj akarok
egy kicsit beszélgetni de viszont
elindult egy beszélgetés elindult egy
program amit együtt készítettünk és
útközben kezdtem tehát mindig bennem
volt a kíváncsiság azalatt a jó pár hét
alatt hogy ezt miért
csináljátok mert mert rendben van hogy
hogy csináljátok de látszott hogy
lelkesen szolgáljátok ezeket a
fiatalokat és hogy hogy valamilyen célja
van de mi a célja és most ezen a záró
ünnepségen értettem meg egy kicsit
mélyebben de talán még mindig nem értem
olyan mélyen mint amennyire meg fogom
érteni most ennek a podcastnek a végére
hogy miért is csináljátok ezt a ezt a
képzésorozatot szóval kicsit meséljetek
a mentor programról és meséljetek a
leaders
forolrólm jó íg most azon gondolkozom
hogy honnan is
hogy honnan is honnan is kezdjem de azt
hiszem hogy ezt ezt ezt mégis csak
bukaresttől kell elkezdeni igen igen
mert
bukarestben találkoztam
én csergő robi által akit te is ismersz
akivel te is találkoztál a
záróünnepségen is
a a a leaders alapítvánnyal a a leaders
alapítvány az az hát hosszú évek óta
egészen pontosan a rendszerváltás óta
dolgozik azon
hogy hogy egy olyan egy olyan
mentorprogramot építsen ki ami ami
segíti a fiataloknak a munkapiacon való
elhelyezkedését az abba való
beilleszkedését és én nem jártam végig a
a leaders alapítványnak az iskoláit
csergő végigjárta
én hát én én én kezdtem beszélgetni
velük annak a
lehetőségéről hogy
hogy ők javítanák a saját a saját
szelekciós a diákok
kiszelektálását megcélzó
tevékenységeiket és javítanák ezt minden
programukon nekük van középiskolásoknak
szóló programuk van van egyetemistáknak
szóló programuk és van egy olyan
programuk amit évente két évente egyszer
tartanak meg ami így a a a munkaerőpiac
ambiciózus fiataljainak szól mert hogy
nem csak vállalkozókat szólítanak meg
hanem
megszólítanak nagyokat álmadó fiatal
pedagógusokat
művészeket satöbbi végülis mindenkit és
én én a foglalkoztam minden programmal
ott ilyen szempontból ahogy mondtam hogy
akkor ezeket
a hát nem tudom hogy hogy
minél koherensebb
diák meg
fiatalcsapatok álljanak össze azzal a
céllal főként hogy a lemorzsolódás az az
csökkenjen hát a koherensat az az
életkorra gondolsz itt most hogy hogy
egy osztályból legyenek egy iskolából
legyenek egy egy kztá nem hogy jól
tudjanak együtt működni ühüm hogy hogy
hogy jól hogy jól tudjanak ezek a
diákcsapatok minél jobban tudjanak az
egyének együttműködni és közösen és
közösen
alkotni valamit közösségi projekteket ez
minden minden korosztálynak témája és
akkor
akkor és akkor akkor akkor igen és akkor
akkor ezzel ezzel
foglalkozván hát egy kicsit így mint így
így jártam igazávó a leadersel azt
hiszem mint mint mint te hogy még nem
tudtam hogy mi végre mikor mikor belecs
entem láttam a korporét világba a
a a
vívódásait a a a nálam is akár a magam
korosztályának de a nálam is
fiatalabbaknak hogy hogy megragadják
saját magukat hogy hogy kitapogassák a a
helyüket ebben a ebben a világban a
munkapiacon hogy hogy meglássák az
értelmét a a munkának
és és közben közben pedig pedig pedig
megértettem azt beszélgetsz vén a a a
középiskolásokkal a programra jelentkező
középiskolásokkal a leaders
alapítványnak a középiskolai képzései
szinte minden román városban jelen
vannak kisebbekben nagyobbakban hogy hát
hogy hát ez ez hogy hogy hogy hogy
rengeteg sok kérdés van bennük rengeteg
sok fennakadás de hogy de hogy hogy
hogy nagyon vágynak az elfogadásra én
azt hiszem azt hiszem hogy
ez ez volt az ami ami ott tartott abban
az elköteleződésemben hogy az
alapítványnak segítsem a
munkáját
és és ami aztán aztán megfogalmazta
bennem vagy ami mentén megfog ez a
felismerés mentén fogalmazódott meg
bennem az hogy hogy hogy ezt ezt haza
szeretném hozni ezzel én tudnék fog
hogy hogy ezt ezt lehet
adaptálni magyar
közösségekre mertogy ezek a vívódásai
biztos hogy közösek ennek ennek a
korosztálynak
és és közben azt is megláttam hogy hogy
úgy ahogy te nagyon jól megragadtad hogy
ezek a
mentorprogramok hogy hogy közben azt is
azt is megláttam a a leaders alapítvány
jelentősen kevesebbet fektet ezekre a
mentorprogramokra mint amekkorát mi
igyekszünk fektetni most a szeredai meg
az udvarhelyi képzésen erre de hogy azt
is megláttam hogy hogy egy nagyon erős
szkepticizmus van már akár az én
generációmban is a z generáció irányába
ühümm és
amúgy azt hiszem hogy ez kölcsönös a z
generációnak is egy elég érzek rajtuk
szkepticizmust a például a a
nagyvilággal kapcsolatban corporate
világgal kapcsolatban abszolút abszolút
van ez ez biztos hogy
meg talán azzal az életformával
kapcsolatban amit a szüleiknél láttak
hogy bemennek dolgozni nyolc órát
dolgoznak visszajönnek és tehát hogy
hogy érzek egy egy könnyű
cinizmust mert hogy van is azt gondolom
hogy hogy meg meg megtapasztaljuk nem is
tudom hogy hogy hogy
hogy nem is tudom hogy ez hogy igen hogy
cinizmus ezzel még ezt a szót még mi is
kimondtuk így készüld podcastra de hogy
igen a cinizmus és a szkepticizmus ami
így nagyon mintha talán ezek lennének
így a az elsők amik így eszünkbe jutnak
nekem legalábbis ami eszembe jut erről
hogy hogy az ég generációnak a
viszonyulása illetve ez amit mondtál
arról hogy hogy hogy a például corporate
világra vagy ugye amúgy a amúgy a
munkavilágára hogy
tekintenek pont most beszéltük át tegnap
hogy mennyire volt egy volt egy nagy
élőkönyvtárunk amikor 50 több mint 50
diák vett részt és fiatal szakembereket
hívtunk meg elbeszélgettek néhány óra és
akkor utána nagyon sokan és merem azt
mondani hogy a többsége ha nem mindenki
azt jelezte vissza hogy hihetetlen hogy
most találkoztak először olyan
felnőttekkel akik amúgy elégedettek az
életükkel meg szeretik a munkájukat hogy
ők számukra ez egy új dolog volt én nem
tehát én nem gondoltam volna ott voltak
15-től 19 évesig és hogy tényleg így ne
már tényleg vannak felnőttek akik akik
ennyire lelkesen tudnak beszélni a
munkájukról hogy ez nem egy olyan dolog
ezek szerint amivel ők ők napi szinten
találkoznak fú nagyon hihetetlenül sok
téma felmerült egyet bedobok még mielőt
vol még én még csak ott ott ott
kerekítenék hogy még egy még egy másik
másik felismerésem ami ami szintén így
így a a a corporate világ és a a civil
szférában való tevékenykedés ötvözetéből
született az az hogy hogy és hogy lehet
hogy hogy itt itt tényleg igaz az hogy
engem elkényeztetett az élet de hogy én
egy olyan olyan családi közegből jöttem
ahol
ahol egyrészt figyeltek rám
és és másrészt segítettek abban hogy
felismerjem az erősségeimet meg hogy
azok mentén építkezzek
és azt azt azt döbbenetes volt
megtapasztalni hogy hogy hogy milyen sok
teljesen jóképességű
10edikes
11-es nek az egyetlen mozgatórugója az
az hogy már már abban a zsenge korában
hogy a kudarcot elkerülje hm
illetve hogy igen tényleg a túlnyomó
többség sajnos nem olyan háttérből jön
úgy tűnik a tapaszt az eddigi
tapasztalataink alapján ahol azt
mondhatnák el hogy hogy hogy minden elő
volt teremtve számukra ahhoz hogy hogy
növekedjenek és virágozzanak és
megismerjék magukat és hibákat
kövessenek el tanuljanak belőlük nag
talán ez a a a nagyon-nagyon ritka aki
azt tudja mondani hogy én ténylegesen
ilyen háttérből jövök családi háttér meg
meg társadalmi háttér
igen itt nagyon sok téma felmerült egy
párat most így körbejárnék mielőtt még
tovább mennénk mert azt hiszem hogy meg
fogunk érkezni ahova szeretnénk én én
először ezzel a cinizmussal magamban
akkor találkoztam amikor ugyancsak
elkezdtem dolgozni egy nagy corporate
cégnél és az első nap fogadott egy ilyen
kicsi kártyácska amin írta a víziót és a
missziót és az értékeket igenigen és én
lelkesen felolvastam magamba és én én én
tényleg azt mondtam vá mi legyünk a
legjobb nem tudom micsoda céged valami
ilyesmi volt a víziója és emlékszem
amikor így elolvastam akkor a mellettem
levő személy
egy cinikus ilyen röhögéssel egyet röhög
na elolvasta a víziót persze mi legyünk
a legjobbak és úgy eleint nem is akartam
ezt én figyelembe venni azt mondtam hogy
na nem nem tudom miért mondta ezt de de
mi leszünk a legjobbak és és három év
alatt lassan láttam ahogy ahogy ez a
lelkesedés a munkatársaimból kihal
jönnek fiatalok akik szeretnének újítani
de de nem lehet amiatt mert a rendszer
éppen azt mondja hogy ezt most nem lehet
és és az ember az értelem értelem
nélküli szenvedést nem tudja elviselni
tehát hogy ha nem tudja hogy miért kell
valamit elviselni akkor azt nem tudja b
viszont az ellenkezője is igaz hogy az
ember képes elviselni ha valami értelmes
az értelmes szenvedéseket képesek
vagyunk elviselni erre utaltál erika
hogy az értelmet keressük folyamatosan
amúgy az mi generációnk is de az é
generáció annál inkább és abban a tehát
hogy azt látom hogy az a cinizmus talán
onnan jöhet hogy az aki a aki nem
értelmet fogalmaz meg valami nem egy
történetbe hívja el a a egy kalandra
hívja el a fiatalokat hanem hanem
mondjam úgy hogy értelmetlen dolgokra
hívja abban a pillanatban az automatikus
reakció szerintem a cinizmus és ez azért
foglalkoztat engem ez a ez a kérdés a z
generációval kapcsolatban mert hát
egyrészt az hogy hogy elhívtak engem
három évvel ezelőtt hogy egy bérmálkozás
felkészítőn beszéljek és három előadást
kellett tartsak pont a annak a
korosztálynak aki aki cinikus aki
telefonál miközben vagy telefonozik
miközben beszélünk és és kíváncsi voltam
hogy hogyan tudom megfogni az ő
figyelmüket mi az amitől figyelni fognak
mi az amitől tisztelni fognak anélkül
hogy tegyük fel erőszakot tehát hogy mi
vonzóvá tegyem azt amit mondok és
ráadásul egy keresztény közek hogyan
fogom vonzóvá tenni a a a a a
kereszténységnek az alapelveit úgyhogy
ez ez nagyon sokat foglalkoztatott de
ebbe az évbe tehát egész jól m ment az
első év második alkalommal egy kicsit
elbíztam magam az az igazság és
felkészületlenül mentem és nem ment
annyira jól nem ment rosszul se de
éreztem hogy ennél sokkal jobban
mehetett volna j van bennem úgyhogy most
harmadik évre úgy döntöttem hogy addig
fogok készülni ameddig csak tudok mind a
három képzésre külön készültem de külön
elkezdtem foglalkozni magával a z
generációval hogyan kell megszólítani
őket hogyan kell kinézzen egy
prezentáció hogy mi az ami
foglalkoztatja őket és hogy miért
foglalkoztatja őket úgyhogy pont ezzel
párhuzamosan jött ennek a steigerw kris
a generációkutatónak a podcastje és
utána elolvastam a könyveit úgyhogy hogy
egy kicsit majd beszélgetnék erről vagy
akár most is bele mehetünk hogy milyen
ez a generáció itt megemlítettél egy pár
dolgot hogy félnek a kudarctól miért
félnek a kudarctól mi is féltünk a
kudarctól nem tudom hogy hogy te
visszaemlékszel-e erre de mi is
próbáltunk szürkék és láthatatlanok
lenni itt csak a magam nevében tudok
beszélni de hogy de hogy hogy
utaltam arra is hogy hogy egy egy egy
támogató családból jövök hogy hogy a
támogató közegnek az elfogadó közegnek a
megléte szerintem ez ami ez ami ami ami
döntő faktor üüm mert mert lehet úgy
félni a kudarctól hogy közben van ez az
elfogadó közeg amire azért azért
azért támaszkodhat az ember amiből
merítkezhet az a ember vagy lehet úgy
félni a kudarctól hogy csak a nagy semmi
van és én ezt tapasztalom hogy hogy az
ők kudarctól való félelmük
az az nagyon nagyon sok esetben meg
nagyon sok mindenkinek ebből a
korosztályból a valahogyan meghatározó
élménye pont a tegnap a tegnap
tehát a szégyenérzet amihez kapcsolódik
hogy potenciálisan
megszégyenülnek mert a kudarcal
gyakorlatilag ott van hogy
alkalmatlannak alkalmatlanná válnak igen
ez a ez a nem akar a világ engem ühüm és
így í így most két két dolog jut még
eszembe az egyik az egyik amit amiből
amit amit olvastunk a tegnap a a thomas
mannak a a beleolvastunk meg olvastunk
róla inkább thomas mannak a józsef és
testvérei könyve regényeposza
hogy hogy ott ott a a a családi vagy az
atyai átok üüm hogy hogy hogy jákobná
végül is meg áldja az összes
fiát de hogy ezen az áldáson belül van
akit akit akit mégis csak megátkoz de
hogy ez a ez az áldáson belül belül
történik tehát a sorrendiség az fontos
és hogy és hogy ez és hogy ez nagyon
fontos és és nagyon nagyon jól meg van
ragadva
a popper péter egyik könyvében is
találtunk erre utalást vagy találtam
erre utalást amit rékának is megmutattam
nagyon jól meg van ragadva vagy nagyon
jó szó van használva arra hogy hogy hogy
az ember faraghatja a gyermekét és nekem
ez a faraghatja ez nagyon tetszik mert
ez egy ilyen nagyon finom valahogy egy
ilyen nagyon szépítő
munkát takar igen nem egy durva igen meg
hogy itt ugye figyelembe veszi az ember
mikor mikor farag eleve az anyagnak a
lehetőségeit ez szerintem nagyon-nagyon
fontos
ü de hogy ebben az elfogadó közegben
végülis bármivé lehet faragni a
gyermeket de hogyha nincs meg ez az
elfogadó kz közeg akkor akkor akkor csak
a megsemmisülés van hm és amit még
gondolok
hogy valahogy rendben van az azt hiszem
hogy a fiatal generáció cinikus az
irányunkban
ühüm de hogy mi erre nem válaszolhatunk
cinizmussal ühüm és és valahol ezt hozza
a leadersnek a mentorprogramja meg azt
hozza az a nagyon erős felismerés amiről
te beszéltél hogy megtapasztalni azt
hogy hogy odaállnak
melléd az alkalmazók azt mondtad te és
hogy és hogy nem ebben a szerepükben
állnak oda mellét hanem abban a
szerepben hogy hogy hogy úgy szellemi
úgy személyes
és úgy úgy szakmai meg emocionális
érésedet érésedet kiteljesedésedet
segítsék hogy hogy hogy ezt ezt azt
hiszem hogy csak mi tudjuk meg tehát
hogy
ehhez nem tehát az autoritás kell ezt
ezt ezt ezt nem nem nem ezt nem tudják
ők ők kiharcolni tizenévesen ezt mi
tudjuk megadni nekik 30 pluszosan 30
évesen huson pluszosan hogy hogy hogy
hogy igenis nyitunk feléjük szóval hogy
talán először mi kell leveszközzük a
cinizmusunkat meg a szkepticizmusunkat
amit még említettünk ahhoz hogy hogy
megszülessen az együttműködés és ahhoz
hogy ők megtapasztalhassák azt hogy hogy
van egy elfogadó közeg hogy van valahol
egy védőháló üüm igen a a cinizmussal
kapcsolatban még azt megemlítené nem
tudom hogy mi a véleményetek róla hogy
egrész a cinizmus véd védi a fiatalokat
és a másik pedig az hogy azért véd mert
a naivitásnál az gyermeki naivitásnál
sokkal jobb cinikusnak lenni
mert mert ez a gyermeki naivitás ez
csak kiszolgáltatottá teszi őket viszont
a felnőttek amit tudnak adni az a fajta
nem naív bizalom ami ami túl szárnyalt a
cinizmuson tehát hogy hogy úgy nyújtjuk
ki a kezünket a másik fele hogy tudjuk
hogy beleharaphat a másik fél ennek
ellenére kinyújtjuk a kezünket versus a
gyermek amelyik kinyújtja és nem tudja
hogy megharaphatja valaki és a a
cinizmus az egy kösztes lépcsőfok amit
jó ha meglép de nem jó hogyha ott marad
egyetérthetek ezzel a igen abszolút az
azért azért is mert hogy az van a
fejemben hogy hogy hogy a a
cinizmus védekező miben léte véget
mindig fenntartja a távolságot igen
igen igen én is azt hiszem hogy talán
nagyon-nagyon sok félelmet látok
mindenek előtt ez amit a leginkább látok
a a középsulisokban akikkel dolgozunk
nagyon-nagyon sok félelmet és tegnap
amikor erikával erről beszélgettünk
akkor fogalmazódott meg úgy igazán
bennem amire amúgy azelőtt is gondoltam
egyrészt azt hogy én nem tudom hogy mit
csinálnék hogyha most lennék tiéves mert
annyira a a világ dolgai annyira el
vannak fajulva meg annyira káosz van
hogy konkrétan megfogalmazódott bennem
és ezt tegnap egy egy folytatódó
beszélgetésben az unokatestvérem mondta
ki hogy konkrétan úgy néz ki hogy azt
mondjuk a fiataloknak hogy ti vagytok a
világ jövője de amúgy a világnak nincsen
jövője sok szerencsét hm merthogy ott
van a ott van tehát a a a zöld ugye a
zöld problémáink a a a globális
felmelegedés a háborúk a természeti
katasztrófák akkor azon belül a ugye
lehet egy csomót hallani a pénznek a az
értékéről elértéktelenedéséről nem tudom
tehát hogy olyan nehéz kinézni a világba
és látni a világ dolgait amihez ugye
nekik most már teljes hozzáférésük van
bármikor az interneten keresztül hogy
tehát nem is tudom hogy hogyan hogyan
legyen egy 156-7 éves fiatalnak
bátorsága és bizalma ahhoz hogy igenis
meglépje a következő lépést és a
következőt úgy hogy közben olyan
minthogyha egy ilyen mint hogyha
damoklés kardja a fejed fölött lenne
folyamatosan hogy amúgy nézd ki a
világba nézd meg hogy ez ez
nagyon-nagyon lefele megy a lejtőn és
rohamosan és azt hiszem hogy ezzel ezzel
nehéz vitat zni így hogyha most most
tényleg kinézünk a a világba hogy hogy
hogy minden minden jó mellett ami mindig
is lesz mert hogy jó és rossz mindig
volt együtt de hogy hogy azért nagyon
felvett egy olyan irányt a a világ ami
ami tényleg ijesztő és akkor ők ezt
látva hogy mégis merjenek tervezni
akarjanak tervezni tudjanak tervezni
bízzanak a körülöttük levőkben magukban
bízzanak egy egy szebb jövőben ami ugye
ők és akkor minden mellett a nyomás
mellett valószínű hogy hogy az én
reakcióm is az lenne hogy lekapcsolok
cinizmust választom kinevetem magamat az
előtt azért hogy mások ne nevethessenek
ki vagy vagy leírom magam azért hogy ne
más írjon majd le hamarosan engem ühüm
és hogy hogy talán ezt látom hogy hogy
nagyon-nagyon sok félelem még akkor is
hogyha ez így nem tudatosul vagy nem így
mondják ki hogy amúgy én félek hát a
legkeményebb témához elérkeztünk mármint
hogy az egyik ami ami foglalkoztat engem
is hogy a világ az valóban tényleg egy
sötét hely ahol egyre sötétebbé válik
minden vagy van-e egy optimista vízió
ami ami talán az ellenkezője ennek mert
ez ezt ezt a fajta világképet ezt már a
60-as évek óta sőt már régebb óta lehet
hallani hogy
hogy 2000-re azt jósolták hogy itt
masszív éhénységek lesznek hogy
túlnépesedés lesz hogy hogy a 60-as
években még a a a a jégkorszaktól féltek
hogy minden le fog hűlni utána aztán a
felmelegedéstől tehát és ezek nem
történtek meg sőt a a bizonyos
szempontból a világunk sokkal pozitívan
mint bárki aki gondolta volna ennek
ellené tehát a a statisztikák ezt
mutatják mert éhénég nincs ahhoz képest
ami volt ezelőtt például 150 évvel
ezelőtt mindenki éhezett mindenki ha
most valaki 150 évvel ezelőtt
150 évvel ezelőtti személynek azt mondta
volna hogy lesz majd olyan idő amikor
sétálhatsz a parkba nem kell reggeltől
estig dolgozz és a hat gyermeked közül
nem hal meg egy sem
és és lesz nyugdíj és lesz fogorvos és
lesz
ingyenes oktatás é tehát azt mondja hogy
ilyen nincs ez a mennyország tehát hogy
hogy ilyen nem fog megtörténni pláne a
mi kicsi hazánkban és ez ez manapság a a
a hétköznapunk amivel elégedetlenek
vagyunk
úgyhogy szóval hogyan hogyan birkóztok
meg ezzel a világ tehát itt valójában
világképbeli harcok történnek ez e mi az
amit a leaders for all hoz be és a
mentor programhoz be milyen történetet
gyakorlatilag itt egy történetről van
szó melyik történetet hisz el a fiatalok
a minden a lefolyóba megy és minden csak
széttörik az életünkbe az entrópia
értelmetlenő széttöri az életünket vagy
pedig vagy pedig mi az
alternatíva én azt hiszem hogy amit
legalábbis én próbálok átadni nekik és
amivel már veled is beszélgettünk erről
egy nagyon picit hogy hogy van hogy
tartós értékek és olyanok amikben nem
amikbe nem éri meg kapaszkodni olyan
dolgok amik nem rosszak önmagukban üüm
de nem éri meg azt hogy az legyen legen
a az alapja az legyen a amit a három
kismalacmeséből ugye a szalmaháznak
nevezünk hogy oké hogy van és n tehát
önmagában nincsen vele semmi gond de de
amikor jön a vihar és nem ha jön hanem
amikor jön ezt szerintem már mindannyian
tapasztaltuk az nem fog megállni és
akkor ez hogy hogy igen lesznek olyan
dolgok amik amik mindig lesznek olyan
dolgok amik mullandók amikben nem éri
meg amikre nem ér meg életet építeni
viszont vannak olyan dolgok amikre igen
és akkor itt próbálunk olyan értékeket
átadni a a tananyagon belül a
mentorprogramon belül magunkból is vagy
a mi saját élettapasztalatainkból amiről
mi hisszük hogy hogy ezekre lehet
építeni ezek azok amik amik ott lesznek
és meg fognak tartani akkor is amikor
jön a vihar és talán ez é azt hiszem
hogy ami aminek itt itt itt helye van
így a te gondolatmenetednek a
folytatásaképpen hogy hogy és talán
talán a a legerősebb ilyen szempontból a
legerősebb érték amit át akarunk adni az
az hogy
hogy közösségi létben való gondolkozás
üüm hogy a közösségnek a megtartó ereje
hogy hogy hogy a generációk
minden rosszat sejtető
hír és és fejléc ellenére össze tudnak
kapcsolódni hogy
hogy
hogy hogy biztos hogy a szegregáció nem
megoldás
és és és nem nem hát nem festi át ezt a
ő képet nem ugyanakkor nem tudom azt
mondani hogy biztos hogy hogy a egy
közösségbe való bekapcsolódás az meg
átfesti de azt gondolom hogy annak már
érdemes egy esélyt adni nem itt a a
közösségben ami ami szerintem nagyon
mély alapelv az az hogy kezdetben egy
közösségbe találja magát egy gyermek és
rájön arra hogy dependens és ahhoz hogy
függetlenné váljon ki kell szakadjon a
közösségből tehát hogy függetlenné kell
tudjon válni de számomra ez volt az
egyik legnagyobb tanulság hogy a
függetlenség nem a legmagasabb szint
ennél sokkal magasabb szint a a a
kölcsönösen függés az amikor ugyanúgy
ahogy beszéltük már nem naívan függök a
többi személytől hanem interdependensek
vagyunk tudatosság és feltételek és
szabályok vannakud és a választásnak a
lehetőségeásnak lehet és sokkalsokkal
produktívabb közösen együtt játszani más
felnőttekkel mint függetlenül valahol
ülni homeoficeba a szobámba és és
elizolálni magamat üüm igen és lehet
hogy lehet hogy egy kicsit kicsit talán
a kultúránk abba az irányba ment el hogy
elhigyük azt hogy a függetlenség a
teljes szabadság mint ahogy te mondod
hogy hogy abban van az igazi szabadság
amikor abszolút nem igen tehát hogy hogy
abban van a teljes szabadság amikor
amikor nincsenek határaim amikor senki
nem mondja meg hogy mit csináljak amikor
senki nem szól bele az életembe én se a
máséba tehát teljesen ilyen leválasztom
magam abszolútan igen igen de ahogy te
is mondtad ez nem de amúgy
pszichológusként kíváncsi vagyok én én
az egyik dolog amit megértettem az az
hogy a a pszichés egészségünk sem
független a a másiktól tehát nem az van
hogy ülök a szobámba és és magamtól
egészséges vagyok hanem gyakorlatilag
outsourceoljuk a pszichés egészségünket
beszélgetünk másokkal akik
visszajeleznek és kontrollálnak minket
hogy a sötét gondolatainkról
visszajelzéseket adnak hogy ez ez nem
elfogadható és és gyakorlatilag egy
egész hierra hiába kell bele
integrálódjunk és az tart minket
egészségesen tehát egyszerre kell én
most magamról beszél egyszerre kell jó
apa legyek jó férj legyek jó munkatárs
legyek egyszerre kell jó közösségi tag
legyek és hogyha ezt a játékot ami
nagyon komplex játék párhuzamosan tudom
játszani ennek van egy megtartóereje
tehát hogy pszichésen is például a
depresszió
inkább elkerül mintogyha ülök a szobámba
nyilván és céltalanul élem az életemet
igen teljesen teljesen meg már eleve az
azt hiszem hogy amikor van egy
problémánk nagyon könnyű elhinni főleg
gondolom ttinnédzsereknél de bárkinek
hogy hogy senki hogy azért senki nem ért
meg meg oké hogy mindenkinek vannak
problémái ilyen azért nincsen és hogy
igen hogy azt megtapasztalni hogy amikor
valaki jön és azt mondja hogy figyelj én
is ezt végigcsináltam vagy ennek egy
hasonló verzióját egy egy idősebb
valószínűleg egy idősebb személy aki aki
azt tudja mondani hogy gyere elmesélem
neked hogy hogy én hogy küzdöttem meg
ezzel vagy elmesélem neked azt hogy ez
hogy én ezt hogy éltem meg ez már
önmagában egy hatalmas hatalmas segítség
és gyógyulási lehetőség amitől
elzárkózunk teljesen hogyha azt mondjuk
hogy nem hát engem senki nem ért meg meg
amúgy is most ilyen senkivel nem történt
nekem a legrosszabb és ezek nem tehát
nem ítélkezéskép mondom azoknak akik így
gondolkodnak mert ténylegesen a klinikai
depressziónak val ez velejár hogy
bezáródsz a fejedbe teljesen bezáródsz a
fejedbe és magadon gondolkoz igen
abszolút magad körül forogsz és nem úgy
hogy beképzelt vagy nem ilyen értelemben
hanem egyszerűen nem tudsz nem tudsz
kifele tekinteni és ebben nagyon sokat
segít a közösség ezért elengedhetetlen
és én én ezt mondanám hogy tényleg
elengedhetetlen nem lehet mentálisan
egészségesnek lenni úgy hogy hogy
független vagy mindent és minden vagy
mindenkitől igen igen és és ott van a
közösségben a szolgálat tehát nyilván
hogyha közösséghez tartozol akkor egy
egy magasabb szintű entitást szolgálsz
mint önmagad és és ahhoz hogy működjön
ez a megvannak a szabályai úgyhogy részt
tudsz venni és és
megtanulhatsz kommunikálni megtanulhatsz
bizniszelni másokkal megtanulhatsz
feltételeket szabni nemet mondani
határokat húzni szóval egy izgalmas
dolog ez a közösség még egy alapelv amit
én szerintem egyet fogunk érten ebbe de
azért feldobnám hogy az elmúlt években
elcsíptem egy másik alapelvet amit a z
generációnak azt tanítják hogy ez nem
igaz de mindenki tudja hogy igaz
mégpedig a fejlődés alapelve ez vagyis
azt jelenti hogy ha ha egy gyermek meg
kell meg akar tanulni futni előtte meg
kell tanuljon járni és ha meg akar
tanulni járni akkor előtte meg kell
tanuljon kúszni van egy egy sorrendiség
minden mer ez teljesen természetes tehát
mindenki tudja amikor egy ilyen példáról
van szó például hogy ha zongorázni akar
valaki akkor meg kell fizesse azt az
árát hogy megtanuljon zongorázni a sok
ezer óra gyakorlás amikor senki nem lát
nem nem kikerülhető mert eljátszhatom
hogy én zongor nagyművész vagyok
felveszek egy frakkot és egy ilyen és
úgy nézek ki úgy viselkedek minthogyha
egy zongoraművész é min a jegegyeket is
kezdem árulni pontosan és t fel olyan
helyzetbe hozom magam hogy 1000er embert
meg tudok győzni arról hogy én nagy
zongoraművész vagyok és akkor kimegyek
és akor a frakkomat szépen lehajtva
leülök attól még nem fogok zongorázni
egyszerűen nem lehet kikerülni ezt a
fejlődés alapelvet de viszont az a az az
érdekes hogy a világunkbaan elkezdtek
játszani ezzel az alapelvvel elkezdik
elhitetni a ezzel az égenációval hogy
kikerülhető a fejlődésnek ez az alapelve
például lehetsz egyből gazdag anélkül
megfizetnéd az árát hogy lehetsz
influencer például és zéró energiával
amit befektetsz vehetsz ilyen
mazerátikat magadnak és és élheted ezt
az életet de ez nem igaz egyszerűen nem
ez amúgy úgy nevezik hogy merisu
effektus ez a merisu ez a nem tudom
hallottátok-e ezt a a kifejezést ezt a
mis e e ez egy ilyen fiktív karakter
amelyik valamilyen rejtélyes módon
szuper képességekkel rendelkezik nem
lehet tudni hogy honnan van ez a
képesség de de de de mindent meg tud
oldani és például nézzétek meg hogy a
filmeknek jó része most most értem ezek
a nagy mainstream filmekre mint például
az egyik a legújabb star wars ahol ahol
volt ray assiszem úgy hívták a főhőst
ő nem lehet tudni de a poros bolygónak a
kellős közepén hirtelen olyan jy jedy
erővel bír hogy minden egyes jedt le tud
győzni a hierarchiát ahol évszázadokon
és ezredeken keresztül egy hagyomány egy
egy egy hierarchia alakult ki amit meg
kell fizetni ahova önfegyelem kell
alázat kell ismeretség kell önfeláldozás
kell na de ez a mérisu hirtelen a
semmiből a legnagyobb jedyit is le tudja
győzni és ezzel próbálják
úgy érzem hogy hogy hogy ezt kell újra
megtanítsuk például mint alapelv hogy
meg kell fizetni az árát a dolgoknak meg
kell fizetni az ár én is megfizettem de
te is meg kell fizetd mert egyszer en
kudarc kudarc után fog jönni hogyha nem
vagy hajlandó megfizetni az árát a
dolgoknak igen valahol talán ez is
megint a kultúránknak a része hogy hogy
újra kell ahogy te is mondtad újra kell
tanítsuk a gyerekeinknek meg a
fiataloknak azt hogy nem baj ha nehéz
mert egy ilyen kényelem egy ilyen
kényelem kultúrában amiben vagyunk meg
hogy tényleg el vagyunk nagyon
kényelmesedve azt hiszem hogy a
legtöbbünk ezt elmondhatja és hogy
nagyon kiváltságos helyzetben vagyunk
valahol beszivárgott a a tudatunkba az
hogy hogy bármi ami kellemetlen nekem
bármi ami rossz érzés ab ab a
pillanatban az nem kívánatos abból
menekülni kell annak vége kell legyen
holott ahogy te is mondtad mindannyian
tudjuk hogy egyrészt fájdalom nélkül
nincs fejlődés hogy hogy a legnagyobb
változások a legnagyobb pozitív
változások sokszor a legnagyobb
krízisekből kerülnek ki nem kell
megijedni a krízis helyzetektől nem nem
kell félni attól és nem kell tehát nem
nem így kéne hozzáállni hogy hogyha egy
picit is rossz akkor akkor akkor akkor
menekülni akkor bezárkoózni akkor véget
vetni annak hanem hogy hanem úgy hogy
ezen keresztülmenni hogy erre úgy
tekinteni mint hosszú táv hosszabb távon
tekinteni úgy tekinteni hogy hogy oké ez
most történik én szoktam mondani ezt egy
nagyon kedves barátnő mondta régebb hogy
hogy az ő nagymamája mindig azt mondta
neki hogy ne úgy gondolj a dolgokra mint
amik veled történnek hanem úgy mint amik
érted történnek hogy amikor amikor
valami valami nagyon nehézségben van az
ember és ez tényleg lehet egy egy valami
nagyonnagyon borzalmas nagy nehézség
tudok-e tudok-e úgy gondolni rá vagy úgy
tudom-e úgy megélni azt hogy rendben
egyrészt tudni azt hogy ez ez csak
időszakos üm másrészt mit tudok tanulni
ebből hogyan figyelni igen igenig igen
nem csak nem csak passzív igen pontosan
nem csak áldozata lenni és akkor
felvenni teljesen ezt az áldozat
magatartást hogy hát persze hogy velem
történik és hogy hogy akkor akkor így
megadni magad ennek vagy pedig vagy
pedig tényleg azt mondani hogy hogy mit
tudok ebből tanulni hogyan tudok ebből
ebből úgy kikerülni hogy hogy valamit
valamit hozzáadjon és nem csak magamhoz
hanem mondjuk akár a környezetemhez is
valahogy egy kicsit így meg élni és itt
megint a közösségi gondolkodás egy
kicsit bejön de hogy hogy igen hogy ezen
ezen átmenni nem beleragadni nem
beleülni nem ezt mondom semmiképpen de
de hogy hogy átmenni rajta úgy hogy hogy
nem nem tudom mi a magyar szó er ez az
embracing a nehézséget is igen hogy
magad hozoleld a nehézséget magad
hozoleld azt is ami nagyon-nagyon fáj
éppen akkor ami kellemetlen persze ebben
benne van ez is a az értelmes szenvedés
úgymond tehát az a fajta szenvedés
aminek aminek az értelmes és önként
vállalt szenvedés
igen igen ami ugye ami ugye van ilyen is
és persze tudjuk hogy van nagyon sok
amit nem önként vállalunk azokat is meg
kell tanuljuk ha benne vagyunk igen
mondhatunk rá hogy hogy rendben vagyunk
benne van nem fogok menekülni előre ja
igen igen ilyen értelemben persze persze
persze és milyen érdekes így a
történetekkel kapcsolatban erika nem
tudom el fogod-e felejteni ezt hát ha
nem jó én nem fogom elfelejteni h mit
mondtál jó jó jaj jó hogy hogy az az az
van még a fejemben hogy hogy ez ez ez a
leaders foró nak is a programunknak egy
ilyen örökös küszködése hogy hogy hogy
ugye mi mi nem nem az azonnal megjavít
azonnal összerak azonnal kitalálja az
életedet azonnal szakmát ad a kezedbe
varázstablettát vagy varázsspirulát
hirdetjük üüm hanem hanem m 10 dolog
amivel tuti gazdag leszel igen igen
hanem hogy hogy azt mondjuk hogy hogy
gyertek el a képzésünkre de hogy ezzel
kell vállalnotok négy-öt hónap munkát
ühüm és ez és ez és ez ijesztő és és és
próbálunk fogást találni és
társasjátékba közösségi társasjátékba
beleépíteni és
úgy kimondani hogy nem mondjuk ki mert
hogy mert hogy nyilván rájöttünk hogy a
hogy hogy a munka az az
negatív kom belefektet teht az hogy
energiát kell beletegyek időt energiát
kell beletegyek valamibe ez úgy ahogy te
is megfogalmaztad ez már nem kecsegtet
ühüm
a de hogy nem azt hiszem hogy nem
kecsegtető első hallásra mert aztán
hogyha hogyha beleáll ebbe az ember
akkor akkor akkor megérti az a 16-17
éves és ezt már a záró eseménye a
leadersnek nagyon jól visszaadja igen
hogy nagyon jól meg tudják fogalmazni
mind hogy hogy mekkorát fejlődtek
mekkorát tapasztaltak igen hogy mekkora
mekkora megért de hogy de hogy nagyon
nehéz ezt a munkát eladni márpedig
márpedig hogy hogy nincs az önismeretre
én tényleg hiszem hogy nincs az
önismeretre a fejlődésre saját magad
karbantartására nincs más esélyed csak
csak ez hogy megdolgozod ühüm és és és
nem és senki nem fogja kitalálni
helyetted hogy pont pont milyen
szakmákba érdemes beleállnod vagy mi az
ami ami ami talán nem a te utad és nem
fogja senki kitaposni helyetted de hogy
de hogy ez ez igen ez kecsegtető ezzel
újra meg újra találkozunk ez kecsegtető
hogy hogy én egyből tudjak zongorázni én
egyből tudjak szaladni ha tetszik ez az
epizód akkor kérlek iratkozz fel a
csatornánkra vagy írd meg kommentbe hogy
milyen más témáról hallanál még szívesen
igen azt hiszem hogy annyira kiagyunk
éhezve az értelmes dolgokra és az
értelmes kihívásokra hogy én én most azt
látom hogy egy egyik egyik oldalról
félünk hogy nehéz eladni másik oldalól
sóvárognak a fiatalok hogy ezt hallják
mert valójában mögötte a történet az egy
örök történet tehát a sárkányölő szent
györgnek a története amikor nekivágunk a
sárkánynak megöljük és elvesszük a
kincsét és visszahozzuk és szétosztjuk a
többiek között ebbe annyi minden
információba bele van kódolva egyrészt
mi is mi mi a sárkány a sárkány minden
amitől az emberiség félt félt a tűztől
félt a gyíkoktól félt a repülő dolgoktól
félt a ragadozóktól tehát hogy a sárkány
ez egy ez egy összegyúrt mitologóikus
formája a félelmünnek a farkastól hogy a
három kismához isérün k a a sárkány a
felmérő a sárkány azf a sárkány a
párkapcsolat ahol nem félünk kimondani
az igazságot mert lehet hogy el fog
hagyni minket a párunk hogyha igazán
merünk őszinték lenni szóval ezek
mind-mind sárkányok az életünkben
viszont hogyha mit mit tudunk csinálni a
sárkányal elmenekülünk tőle ha
elmenekülünk kétszer akkorává válik
viszont a másik lehetőség az hogy önként
szembe megyünk vele és hogyha megöljük
azt a sárkányt mármint nyilván itt is
bölcsen kell dönteni mert ha túl nagy
sárkánynak megyünk neki akkor lehet hogy
öön meg minket viszont hogyha a
megfelelő sárkányt kapjuk el akkor lehet
hogy megöljük és ez a furcsaság hogy
minden egyes hüllőnél van valami kéncs
vagy egy egy egy szűzlány akit akit
vissza lehet hozni ki lehet menekíteni
ez történik hogy minden egyes harcunk
ami amit amibe győzünk az egy kincs lesz
számunkra és és tényleg ezt láttam a a a
mentorprogram végén hogy ott sok győztes
volt aki a sárkányával szemb ment
mindenki a sajátjával és hozott
valamilyen kincset és ezzel ez ezt ezt a
kincset egy kicsit megcsillantotta ott
nekünk hogy elmesélte hogy milyen
győzelme volt és akkor a visszatérve a
közösségi élményhez ez a az utolsó lépés
oss szét ossd szét ezt a kincset ne
tartsd meg magadnak hanem azt amit te
megkaptál mi mit jelent ez pont
konkrétan azt jelenti hogy ha jöttél egy
győzel tehát ha már tudod hogy le lehet
győzni a a felmérőt akkor zd meg a
többiekkel is hogy ha kemény munkát
belefektetsz akkor akkor működni fog
nézd meg nekem működik és gyere és
segítek neked segítek neked hogy te is
azon a felmér át tudj menni még még még
egy egy gondolat jutott eszembe hogy és
azt gondolom hogy hogy
hogy valahol kötelesek vagyunk ezt is
megemlíteni de hogy tényleg nem az újal
mutogatás szándékával teszem hogy azzal
is sokszor szembem megyünk hogy a
tanárok az osztályfőnökök a a az
iskolaigazgatók mondják azt el leve
amikor amikor szembesülnek a a
programunkkal hogy jaj hát ezt erre
ebben az iskolában nem lesznek vevők a
diákok és és hát hogy hogy hogy tényleg
azt látjuk hogy hogy
a ha jót ha ha jót
gondolsz jól fektetsz be akkor annak jó
következménye lesz ez a hozzáállás
viszont tényleg ezt az eredményt szüli
üüm hogy és akkor itt erre van van
elhangzik sok minden nem lesznek vevők a
diákok mert mert hát ez egy szakiskola
javarészt fiúk vannak mit érdekli őket
az önismeret
mert ez olyan ezek szerint hát hogy hogy
a akkor akkor nem lesznek vevők azért
mert ez művészeti legyen szó
csíszeredáról vagy udvarhelyről ez
művészeti hát itt amúgy is túl vannak
terhelve és különben is hát miért függne
össze az önismeret meg a közös lét azzal
hogy te sikeres művész leszel-e vagy sem
üüm és miért függ össze
kicsit provokáljalak hát hogy hogy na
várjál merr mert igen majdnem elmondtam
amit
akartam jó fejezd be akkor ezt a
gondolatot na hogy hogy hogy vissza és
válaszolok a kérdésedre csak hogy azzal
azzal akartam azzal akartam befejezni
ezt a gondolat m tet hogy itt ismét az
van
hogy hogy támogat-e a közeg abban hogy
ühüm elhiszi-e rólam a tanárom az
osztályfőnököm hogy én érdemes vagyok
arra hogy belevágjak egy ilyen
önismereti
pályaorientációs közösségi kalandba
van-e legalább egy félnőtt aki aki
elhiszi nekem és aki aki nem nem arról
beszél hogy ennek a vállalásnak a
nehézségeiről hanem inkább az abéli
meggyőződésemet erősíti meg hogy ez
hosszútávon a hasznomra válik és azt
tapasztaljuk hogy nagyon kevés ilyen
felnőtt van és ez
igen ez ez ez ez szerintem egy egy
óriási nagy baj hogy hogy hogy egyrészt
a kritikát azt halomra fogalmazzuk az
elvárásokat azt halomra
fogalmazzuk de hogy közben meg
egyáltalán nem állunk bele abba hogy mi
magunk támogatói legyünk annak hogy ez a
fiatal generáció ez utat találjon
magának és beszélünk az égenációról de
hát közben meg ott az alfa hogy akkor
akkor akkor mi lesz mi lesz tovább
merthogy mertogy merthogy nem
nem nyilván ez ez ez ez vitatható hogy
de hogy én én én nem látom azt hogy
hogy ebben köteleződne el a felnőtt
társadalom és akár a pedagógusok
társadalma hogy hogy mégis csak
levetkőzzük az előítéleteket és és
tényleg segítői legyünk akár mentorai
legyünk a ránk bízott fiataloknak ami
ami fájdalmas nekem ebben ahogy
fogalmaztál hogy alig kerül egy felnőtt
de a a ami igazán fájdalmas számomra az
az hogy olyan kevés biztatás kell az
embernek hogy már egy kicsi virágot
kierjen mutatni magából tehát hogy hogy
a én a mentor és a mentoráltaimat
igyekeztem bátorítani de nem volt olyan
sok bátorítás tehát hogy nyilván az
alatt a hat hét alatt én nem tudtam
rendszeresen beszélgetni velük mondjam
úgy hogy hetente egyszer kétszer
beszélgettünk az az nagyon kevés és már
ez ez ez ezérra nagyon hálásak voltak az
azt a kevés bátorítást amit kaptak tőlem
már az is nagy dolog volt számukra és
tehát hogy ez szomorít el benem hogy
miért miért olyan nehéz bátorítani mást
lehet hogy nekünk is amúgy bátorításra
van szükségünk abban hogy mást
bátorítsunk és nem csak abban igen igen
merthogy merthogy igen merthogy amúgy
amúgy tényleg tényleg hihetetlenül
hálásak tudnak lenni szóval hogy hogy
így a a a záróünnepség utána hogy most
nem hogy a trénereiket ahogy ahogy
megölelik vagy nem hogy a mentoraikra
amilyen csillogó szemmel néznek hanem
hanem én aki aki reálisan nem
kapcsolódok
velük jelen vagyok többékevésbé jelen
vagyok de hogy még még engem is
érdemesnek tanít tartanak egy-egy
egy-egy
megölelésre hogy hogy hogy hogy amúgy
nagyon hálásak tudnak tényleg én ezt
tapasztalom hogy végtelenül hálásak
tudnak lenni hogyha hogyha nem tudom
kapnak egy kis k marékföldet hogy ugye
térjünk vissza a mesékre történetekre
egy kis marékföldet amibe egy-két
varázsmangjukat elültethetik hm
igen és azt hiszem hogyha hogy lehet
hogy ez nagyon mére is nyúlhat vissza
mert az hogy az hogy ha ha nem azt
kapják vagy nem úgy nőnek fel mert talán
már az elődeig sem így élték meg hogy az
élet értékes a te életed értékes amit
mondtál te is erika hogy ha nem gondolom
magam érdemesnek arra vagy ha nem
gondolom magam értékesnek miért
fektetnék bármiféle erőfeszítést magamba
tehát akkor persze hogy hogy ha nem
látom a saját értékem a saját életem
értékét úgy ahogy vagyok és ez is egy
olyan dolog ami egy ilyen egy ilyen
alapelvünk meg amit nagyon próbálunk a
képzésen belül tovább adni az az hogy
ami egy nagyon egyszerű meg már majdnem
elcsépeltnek tűnő gondolat ez hogy
értékes vagy de mi viszont megpróbáljuk
alátámasztani ezt amit mondunk és
lehetőséget adunk nekik arra hogy
megtapasztalják hogy ez tényleg így van
szóval hogyha nem nem gondolják úgy hogy
ők értékesek akkor persze hogy nem
fognak akarni négy-öt hónapig viszonylag
keményen vagy akár nagyon keményen
dolgozni önmagukért másokért együtt
egyénileg és lehet hogy lehet hogy hogy
itt is itt is el van egy kicsit csúszva
a dolog hogy talán abbahagytuk azt hogy
hogy hangsúlyozzuk az életértékét az
egymás
értékétm az értelem amit mondtál ugye
hogy hogy gyere gyertek akkor akkor hadd
mutassuk meg hogy mi az értelme hogy
igenis van értelme hogy nem véletlen
hogy itt vagy hogy nem mindegy hogy itt
vagy-e ezek olyan gondolatok amikkel
valószínű hogy már az é generációból is
sokan nem találkoztak de bele se merek
gondolni hogy az alfa generá milyen
talán mennyire ez már teljesen ki lesz
veszve hogyha hogyha nem teszünk ez
ellen úgy értem
igen így a a ez egy nagyon jó kérdés egy
kicsit beszélgetnék erről is h az ember
miért értékes üüm mert úgy tűnik
minthogyha egy felületes mindenki
értékes és legyünk kedvesek egymással
szinten marad és akkor persze jön a
cinizmus mert amikor látják a fiatalok
hogy hogy mindenkire azt mondjuk hogy
értékes ez olyan mint hogyha mindenkinek
kupát adnánk a a ot itt a verseny és
mindenki első díjat kap és és akkor
persze már teljesen értelmét veszti a
verseny önmagában mert mert valójában a
versenyszellemiségét csúfoljuk meg
úgyhogy felmerül a kérdés hogy miért
értékes mindenki és ez számomra akkor
változott ez az egész meg az én szívemen
mert én őszintén nem gondoltam hogy
mindenki
értékes valahogy volt bennem egy
arrogancia ezelőtt körülbelül hogyha 10
évvel visszamegyek hogyha valaki sikeres
akar lenni akkor olyan legyen mint én és
a akkor olyan jellenvonása kell legyen
hogy például alacsony vagyok
neurotikusság az azt jelenti hogy hogy
szeretek rizikót vállalni az aki
neurotikus az az lehet hogy nem annyira
ügyes úgyhogy meg kell tanuljon
kevesebbet stresszelni például ez eg ez
egy tipikus példa
de de mitől értékes az ember és azt az
egyik amire jutottam és e ez ez most
fogalmazom meg így megpróbálom
összerakni lássam mi a véleményetek az
az hogy az ember
ugyanaz az ember egyszerre tud
hihetetlenül undorító lenni és
hihetetlenül izgalmas személy lenni
ugyanaz a személy egyik irányba elindul
és a másik irányba és az egyik irányt
könnyebb egy kicsit végignézni hogy mi
történik az emberrel hogyha az undorító
oldalára megy mert egyrészt látszik hogy
mi történik egy például egy férfival ha
elburjányzik hogy ha ha ha nincs valami
aminek alárendeli a benne levő
potenciált hanem elhízik megkopaszodik
elbutul és és a potenciál lassan fogy
belőle és keserűvé válik és cinikussá és
arrogánssá és és tudom ezt az életutat
látom magam előtt és látom a hajlamomat
nekem is arra hogy hogy hogy kell
küzdjek azzal hogy hogy hogy ne ez ne
ezt csináljam de másik oldalról ami amit
ennél mélyebben lehet látni a 20 század
történelmét végignézve hogy mi történik
akkor hogyha elszabadul ap pookol a
társadalomba végignézve a a azt a 100
millió hullát amit hagyott maga mögött
ez a párttotalitárius rendszer és azokat
hétköznapi emberek csinálták hétköznapi
emberek voltak azok akik gyilkoltak és
és tömeggyilkosokká váltak nem nem
pszichopaták hanem hétköznapi emberek és
van is egy könyv aminek az a címe hogy
átlagemberek és leírja hogy az átlag
rendőr németországba akit bevezényeltek
hogy rendet teremtsen lengyelországba
amit frissen elfoglaltak hogyan vált pár
hónap alatt tömeggyilkossá az átlagember
és ez számomra eg nagyon-nagyon fontos
pillanat volt amikor rá kell hüjek hogy
én mint átlagember képes vagyok arra
hogy a poklot megteremtsem és ha képes
vagyok arra akkor vajon képes vagyok-e a
mennyországot megteremteni és hogyha
igen akkor mit kell feláldozzak magamból
azért hogy hogy hogy hogy a a
mennyország fele toljam el a világot és
hogy az átlagemberek képesek arra is
hogy a mennyországot megteremtsék
nekifeszüljenek gyakorlatilag ez egy
keresztény történet ez e ez a keresztény
történet hogy felveszed a válladra a
keresztet és viszed és és ha azt az azt
az üzenetet adod a fiataloknak hogy
figyeljetek az élet nehéz nehéz lesz
nektek is gyakorlatilag körülöttetek
mindenki meg fog öregedni és meg fog
halni és ti is és lehet hogy ti hamarabb
mint a környezetetek és és azon kívül
pedig bizonyos szempontból igazságtalan
a társadalom és egy csomó mindent fog
érni egy csalódás és fájdalom és
szenvedés az életbe de te több vagy mint
az a fájdalom képes vagy felvenni a
keresztedet és a benned levő potenciál
nagyobb hogy ha figyelsz és alázatos
vagy akkor képes vagy túlszárnyalni
önként vállalva ezt a szenved ez a
keresztény történet és amikor emlékszem
amikor a médiaműhelyre taboroztam
diákokat és mentem iskoláról iskolára
így osztályról osztályra gyakorlatilag
ezt a hangvételt ütöttem meg egy kicsit
kemény voltam velük úgy beszéltem mint
felnőttel mert van egy felnőtt oldaluk
és van egy gyermekoldaluk és ezek a
fiatal felnőttekkel úgy beszéltem mint
felnőtt a felnőtthöz és elmondtam nekik
hogy gyertek és nehéz lesz
jelentkezzetek nehéz lesz nem lesz
könnyű
viszont ti lehet hogy képesek vagytok
megcsinálni fogjatok neki emeljetek fel
valami nehezet mert most itt van a
lehetőség arra hogy tanuljatok és valami
igazi szuper képességet kapjatok és
akkor visszatérve az ön a a a a a az
önismeretre kicsit beszélgetnék erről
hogy mielőtt még az önismeretre rátérünk
bocsánat azt látom hogy ki vannak éhezve
a fiatalok erre hogy ezt hallják hogy ők
képesek valami hihetetlen terhet
felemelni azért hogy a hogy áldás
legyenek a környezetükre sőt ez nem csak
egy opció hanem szüksége van minden
pillanatban esik szét a világunk és
szükség van a a fiatal bátor lélekre
amelyik nekivág és újra összerakja ezt a
világot egy új formájában és amikor ezt
hallják akkor csillog a szemük mert van
értelme az életüknek van egy értelmes
elhívás amiért feláldozhatják az
életüket
így ami ami rögtön beugrott az az a a
próbálkozás bár orsága a tanítómese hogy
hogy tulajdonképpen ez a a vezér mit tud
abban a mesében annyit tud hogy mindenki
mással ellentétben nem fogadja el
tényként hogy az a lakat zárva van hanem
éppen csak megpöccinti és kiderül hogy a
a sok
éve kinyithatatlannak vélt lakat
valójában soha nem volt bezárva ühüm ez
azt gondolom amúgy hogy ez ez lehet
lehet így így külső tört éénet de
nyilván lehet belső története is minden
egyes embernek akkor
viszont viszont válaszol részben a az
általad felvetett kérdésre problémára
meglátásra üüm
hogy
hogy most nem tudom hogy pont szerencsés
fordítás-e hogy vezér üüm
mert merthogy merthogy merthogy merthogy
azt gondolom hogy hogy végülis igen
abban az értelemben igen hogyha
mindannyian a saját életünknek a vezérei
vagyunk üm
de hogy de hogy
hogy ugye ez a ez a ez a bennünk van a
próbálkozásnak a bennünk kell legyen a a
a próbálkozás lehetősége az mindenképp
bennünk van és akkor kérdés hogy hogy
ehhez tudunk-e bátorságot társítaniüm
hogy megmerjük ezeket a lakatokat
tényleg éppen csak pöccinteni mert hogy
erről szól ez a mese hüüm és a a sz
lakatot nem nem magunk miatt kell
feltétlenül kinyissuk hanem a
környezetünk miatt minél több lakatot
kinyitunk annál nagyobb áldást tudunk
tenni a környezetre mert lehet hogy
saját magáér az ember keveset tenne mer
sokszor az van hogy a a az állatokat
amik körülöttünk vannak inkább adunk
nekik gyógyszert mint mi magunk
bevegyünk egy gyógyszert jobban
gondoskodunk néha másról mint magunkról
ez igaz igen pláne aki nem kedveli saját
magát az az nyilván nyilván nem akarja
azt lakatot kinyitni csak csak azért
hogy ki legyen nyitva de amikor körbenéz
és azt látja hogy én erre a szenvedésre
lehető válasz tudok lenni csak nem
vagyok az ami kéne legyek ahhoz hogy
hogy ezt a lakatot ki tudjam nyitni
úgyhogy azzá kell csiszoljam magam azzá
a kulcsá amelyik képes ezt a lakatot
kinyitni
igen igen meg van egy van egy idézet ami
most így elénk jött a nemrég a harry
potterből amikor azt mondja azt mondja
dumlor harrynek hogy hogy nem a
képességeink hanem a döntéseink
határozzák meg azt hogy hogy kik vagyunk
ezt most nem szó szerint idézem és az ön
ismeret ugy ahogy kérdezted hogy hol jön
a képbe az önismeret meg a ez a
közösségi munka akkor amikor valaki
valaki híres művész akar lenni vagy
nagyművész akar lenni igent a levegőben
maradt ez a kérdés igen igen hogy
önismeret nélkül önismeret nélkül nem
fogunk tudni önazonos döntéseket hozni
nem fogunk tudni számunkra jó döntéseket
hozni feltétlenül ha igen akkor
véletlenül
közösségi munka nélkül nem fogjuk tudni
önmagunkat vagy közösség nélkül nem
fogjuk tudni önmagunkat igazán
megismerni mert görbetükrő csak a
közösségünk tudt tartani és mindannyan
tudjuk hogy erre mekkora szükségünk van
nem csak görbetükörre de ahogy te is
mondtad a bátorításokra és hogy hogy itt
jön be az hogy hogy igen önismeret
nélkül nem lehet és igen akard
megismerni magad azért mert mert van
érték amit megismerj mindenkiben igen is
értékes vagy igenis érdemes vagy arra
hogy önmagadba fektess még akkor is
hogyha mondjuk az eddigi tapasztalataid
azok hogy a felnőttek nem különösebben
fektettek beléd vagy nem nem
különösebben mutatták ki azt hogy
érdemes beléd fektm
ühüm így most e eszembe jutott a így
tomy és jerrynek az akármelyik képe van
előttem mert ez egy nagyon sokszor
ismétlődő kép amikor amikor így ugye
pokolmenyország mentén hogy a kis ördög
és az angyal ahogy felül akár tomnak
akár jeryek bizonyos helyzetekben a
váláraü hogy
hogy hát mindig mindig mindig könnyebb a
az ördög hangjával azonosulni ühüm az a
az a az a munkás ahhoz kell a bátorság
meg ahhoz kell az önismeret is hogy hogy
hogy inkább a a az angyal hangjával
tudjunk azonosulni hm ez mekkora
meglátás hogy ha
ha spontánul hagyjuk a dolgokat akkor
lefele sodródunk általában
viszont oda tudatos kell lenni és nagyon
koncentrált fókuszált ahhoz hogy hogy az
ellenkező irányba tudjunk fejlődni a
jobbikat a jobbik oldalunkat és most nem
nem egy külső moralizálásról van szó
hogy én meg mondom neked hogy melyik a
jobbik oldalat hanem valójában magában
mindenki tudja hogy az ő oldala melyik a
jobbik oldal hogyha leül az ágy a
szédére este amikor senki nem látja és
felteszi azt a kérdést hogy melyik az a
három dolog hogy hogy egy picit a stupid
életem egy kicsit kevésbé legyen stupid
egyből jön három dolog egyből jön három
dolog a hogy hogy hogy hogyan tehetnél
jobbá
igen igen csak hogy ugye emelégeesz hogy
jön ez a három dolog aztán ezeket még
integrálni kell végig kell járni az
útját igen és akkor hogyha itt az ördög
azt mond mondja hogy ó hadd a francba
hát nézd meg hogy a a szomszédba
ott sem zöldebb a fű ott sem élnek
másképp akkor sokkal könny sokkal
könnyebb el rábólintani meg ezzel ezzel
azonosulni így megélni ementén megélni a
holnapot a holnap utánt
igen még az önismerethez azt tenném
hozzá lássam hogy mi a véleményetek hogy
ez ez nem egy opció számomra tehát egyre
inkább azt látom hogy az önismeret az
egy szuper képesség ami amivel hogyha
nem rendelkezel egyszerűen lemaradsz és
és a világ komplexitását nem fogod tudni
a válladra venni és nem fogsz tudni
csapatokat vezetni nem fogod tudni az te
életedet a párkapcsolatodat a a a
megélni é
stabil stabilan bele intetegrálódni ebbe
a vertikális hierarchiába amiről
beszélgettünk önismeret nélkül tehát ez
e ez nem egy luxus hogy még akkor é
kicsi önismeret is még jól jön hanem
abszolút egy kelléke a világunknak az
önismeret
a plusz még ez a steigerbá krisztián
arról mesél és nagyon-nagyon jó meglátás
szerintem hogy a jövő azért lesz akinek
önismer tehát könyveket olvas és
rendelkezik egy egy önismerettel igen
igen igen az a az az
azt hiszem hogy nem mondtuk ki explicit
a
felelősségvállalást és ennek a kérdését
hogy hogy
hogy megismerem magam felfedezem a
magamban rejlő értékeket és és akkor
onnantól ez ez a ez a ez a megismerés ez
ez már felelősségvállalásra is is
kötelez mert abban a pillanatban mihelyt
valamit felismertem már nem tehetek úgy
minthogyha nem ismertem volna fel igen
és és tegnap pont a a szent exuperinek a
az idézetét használtuk hogy hogy
minden hogy mindöröké felelősséggel
tartozol azért amit megszelídítettél
pont ez hogy ha én nem most nagyon
gyakorlatias példát mondani hogyha
valaki valaki nem nincs tisztában azzal
hogy hogy ő amúgy egy nagyon-nagyon
áldott vagy nagyon-nagyon tehetséges
szakács akkor senki nem rója azt fel
neki hogy nem nem etette a többieket meg
nem készített tteleket abban a
pillanatban hogy mindenki tudja hogy ez
az ember tudja meg az az ember tisztában
van vele hogy nekem amúgy ez van
tehetségem ténylegesen és nem csinálja
abban a pillanatban már az már egy az
már egy probléma ugye a a a
talentumoknak az esete amikor ülök azon
amin van és és hagyom elkallódni
ahelyett hogy használnám kicsit hogy az
ördög ügyvégyje legyek hogyha most azt
mondanám így fiatal ként oké oké tehát
hogyha ha elkezdem képezni magam akkor
egy csomó teher kerül rám akkor miért
képezzem magam miért jó az hogyha képzem
magam legalább nem kerül rám teher mert
azt hiszem hogy annak a terhe hogy hogy
ülsz magadon és hogy hagyod elveszni a
potenciálod az végső soron mindig
sokkal-sokkal nagyobb lesz mint az a
teher ami ami rád kerül akkor hogyha
hogyha megéled és ugyanakkor azt is
hiszem hogy amint amint egyre több egyre
több terhet érzel magadon ugyanannyival
én ezt tapaszt ugyannyival nő a az
ellenálló képességed is és habár habár
nőnek a terhek is de te is egyre inkább
nőssz ahhoz hogy azokat tudd vinni és a
senkinek nem kívánom meg meg
nagyon-nagyon nem szeretném hogyha több
olyan fiatal lenne aki azt választja
hogy hogy inkább hátradől és nem kezd
magával semmit mert mert az és arról nem
is beszélve hogy ez mekkora teher
másoknak de hogy önmagára nézve hagyni
elkalódni így egy életet annál a
tehernél szerintem nincsen nagyobb ez
mekkora gondolat tehát hogy
gyakorlatilag ha céltalanul éled az
életedet van egy ilyen gondolatunk egy
ilyen mítosz a fejünkben hogy a
céltalanul élt élet az egy ilyen
neutrális állapothoz vezet hogy akkor se
nem jó se nem rossz de valójábítani de
valójában amit te mondasz az az hogy a
céltalan élet az egy elviselhetetlen
szenvedéssel fog járni nem csak neked
hanem a körülötted mindenkinek abszolút
úgyhogy hogy emiatt ne legyen céltalan
az életed az az a az a nagy nagy
pillanata jutott eszembe a csékszeredai
projektek kiértékelésének amikor amikor
az egyik az
egyik fiú mondta azt hogy hogy hogy
majdnem elengedték a projektet az
általuk megálmodott egyik közösségi
projektet és hogy ott fordult át bennük
a a
hozzáállásuk amikor amikor meg ez az
egész történet amikor amikor azt
értették meg a mentoroktól hogy hogy
hogy bánni a meg nem próbálást az sokkal
elviselhetetlenebb lesz mint mint
elfogadni az esetleges kudarcot
üüm
ht de hogy hogy ugye ebben
ebben hogy visszagondolok arra a
pillanatra és egy teljes örömként érte
katartikus volt hogy és ki mondta és
pont ő mondta ki de másrészt meg
meg azt is gondolom hogy az nincs
rendben hogy ezt ezt 17 évesen és egy és
egy mentortól m hallod hogy ez ezt
valahol ezt ezt ezt ezt korábban kell
korábban kell tanítani
igen na na hogy de hogy de hogy hogy még
még még ez a felelősségvállalás témája
szerintem ami így
így és mégis ott van a levegőben hogy
hogy de hogy végülis
igen na nem ez nem nem nem tehát hogy
ezt akartam mondani ami már elhangzott
csak hogy annyira ott volt a fejemben
hog ez e abszolút alap abszolút alap a
felelősségvállalás kérdése hogy nem egy
opci nem nem egy opció az h felősséget
vállalunk-e vagy nem mert megbetegszik a
lelkünk olyanok vagyunk mint a
teherhordóállat hogy kell a teher
rajtunk az optimális teher az értelmes
teher ahhoz hogy egészségesek
legyünk és és hogy hogy mert hogy réka
amíg téged hallgattalak volt ott a
fejemben csak hogy olyan kerek lett a
vége hogy ehhez képest ez már egy kicsit
ilyen ilyen ilyen visszatérünk az
alapokhoz de hogy hogy hogy hogy ezelőtt
három évvel amikor belevágtunk a a
leadersbe amikor megcsináltuk az elő
diszkviselkedés modell teszteket akkor
szembesültünk azzal hogy hogy hogy ugye
hát a diszk mentén lehetsz domináns hüüm
és de hogy hogy a dominancia nem nem nem
feltétlenül jelent jelent vezetést
bár bár hátát a dominály szó igen hogy
igen igen és hogy és hogy é ráásul nem j
se pozitívat se negatívat nem
jelent hogygn ettől a 16-17 évesek ez a
jaj ne nehogy kijöjjön a domináns vagy
jaj ne hogy ja jaj ne kijött az hogy én
domináns vagyok te jó ég hát de akkor
remélem hogy még valami más is vagyok
mert én ezzel a ezzel a dominanciával
mintogyha ez ez megkérné hogy akkor te
kell felelősséget vállalj üüm mintha
jobban megkérné mint a többi szín hogy
te felelősséget kell vállalj mondjuk a
saját életedért és és hogy ezt ezt ezt
nem akarják és én én egészen addig
ezerszer átforgattam a tananyagot ühüm
és és és és megdöbbentem azon hogy hogy
nekem a piros szín ezt egyáltalán nem
üzente ez a piros domináns szín mert az
pont a piros de hogy de hogy hogy
egyáltalán nem nem én én nem fedeztem
fel ebben hogy ettől félni kell ettől
tartani kell ez és hogy és hogy ők
viszont ők viszont viszont rettegnek
ettől a ettől a pirostól mint a tűztől
hogy azt vettem észre hogy ők is így
végén most már poénosan mondták hogy én
domináns vagyok és akkor de de ez
tényleg a disk modell amúgy a hallgató
kedvéér azok akik nem ismerik ez négy
dimenzióra bontja a személyiséget de
mondjuk lehet hogy réka téged kéne
megkérlek inkább hogy mesélj a
dismodellről nyugodtan de akkor inkább
egészítsd ki amit mondok ez a négy
dimenzió számomra azért szimpatikus
amúgy van a a nagy öt személyiség model
ez a big five ennek az alternatívája ami
számomra egy kicsit komplexebb és és
használhatób de a disk is egy egy
csodálatos rendszer ilyen szempontból
ami tetszik nekem az hogy semmi sem jó
vagy rossz hanem valamilyen és és megvan
a kincse annak is aki domináns és van
aki megvan annak annak a kincse is aki
kevésbé domináns mert ugyanúgy tehát
most inkább a a a nagyöt személyiség
modellből tudok mondani egy példát én
végig azt gondoltam hogy a neurotikusság
az rossz a neurotikusság az az hogy
hogyan reagálok a negatív érzelmekre és
vannak akik a negatív
érzelmeket érzékenyebben
fogják fel és vannak akik kevésbé én egy
alacsony neurotikusságú személy vagyok
azt jelenti hogy kevésbé reagálok a
negatív dolgokra a feleségem ennek az
ellenkezője aki magas neurotikusságba és
ez persze úgy jelenik meg hogy hogy
hajlamosabb felkapni a vizet hajlamosabb
szorongani hajlamosabb kev tehát én
hajlamosabb vagyok rizikót vállalni és ő
kevésbé vállal rizikót és akkor persze
arra az volt az egyik következtetésem
hogy az enyém jó és az övi rossz az
elején és rá kell jöjjek hogy ez
egyáltalán nincs így mert megvan az
előnye annak hogyha valaki magas
neurotikusságban mégpedig az hogy
olyanok mint egy érzékeny szenzor ha
valami katasztrófa közeleg ők ők az
elsők akik észreveszik márpedig
katasztrófa közeleg úgy ahogy mondtad az
özönvíz mindig ott leselkedik és
bármikor beönthet úgyhogy a feleségem az
aki először szól hogyha kezd a
kapcsolatunk picit is távolodni tehát az
egy két-három napig nem voltunk együtt
eleget akkor már egyből kezd jelezni az
ő szenzora és az én szenzorom mire
jelezne lehet már már párteráp
párterápiára kéne járjunk ahhoz hogy az
ő részéről még mindig menthető legyen a
sol meg
aőg meg háá egy kell kiegésítük és e ez
ilyen szépen egymásba fonódik és a
diskmodell is hasonló tehát az összes a
domináns és esetleg akkor itt
csatlakozhatnál be egy kicsit a
diszkmellt meséld nekünk mi mi ez a négy
dimenzió hát ez a négy dimenzió
ez afelén spektrumon mozog vagyis ezen a
spektrumon oszlik meg az egyik az
extravertált vagy introvertált hogy
kifele forduló vagy befele forduló
illetve az hogy emberkö pontú vagy
feladatközpontú és akkor ezeknek a
különböző párosításai adják ki ezt a
négy
kategóriát amit most nem fogok tudni
magyarul szerintem elmondani van a igen
van a domináns van a a közösségi ühüm
van
a lelkiismeretes tudatos ez a
conscientious ez mi volt magyarul
tudatos tudatos tudatos és akkor még
volt a a nem
intuitív befolyásolónnak volt fordítva
az i betű de hogy én de hogy hogy én nem
feltétlenül szeretem ezt a ezt a ezt a
fordítást igen a magyar a magyar az meg
most bele is kavarodtam ebbe mert nem
tudom pontosan hogy magyarra hogy
fordítódik hogy mindig úgy fordítódik-e
de ez a lényege hogy ezek mentén ezek
mentén oszlik el és amit amit például mi
nagyon hasznosnak tartunk meg amit
mindig elmondunk és bemutatunk
prezentációval meg ilyen interaktív
beszélgetésben az az hogy egyrészt hogy
mik a mik az erősségeid hogyha mondjuk
rólad kiderül hogy egy egy egy domináns
igen mi az előny ennek amit ugyanakkor
ezzel párhuzamosan elmondunk az az hog
amit mi úgy hívunk hogy az erősségek túl
használata amik a kihívások úgymond
amikre oda kell figyelni ezek nem
gyengeségek hanem ez amikor átfordul
most nagyon konkrét példával amikor egy
domináns személy mindenkit leural de nem
azért mert rő le akar mindenkit uralni
az ő természetes közeg erős igen hanem
annyira hajtja őt azt hogy gyertek
gyerekek csináljuk és meg tudjuk
csinálni és mégis hogy ez másoknak úgy
jöhet le minthá teljesen leurrolt hát
abszolút nem érdekli hogy én itt vagyok
hogy mit akarok holott nem ez a realitás
a domináns fejében csak csak így jön át
és akkor ami még nagyon fontos ebben a
prezentációban ezzel együtt hogy mire
figyeljenek oda vagy hát beszélgetésben
az ez hogy hogy hogyan kommunikálj egy
olyan stí egy más stílusú személel mert
ugye egy munkahelyenüm biztos hogy nem
csak mind egy kategóriából lesznek
emberek és nem is ez lenne a jó mint
ahogy te is mondtad tehát hogy ez
szörnyű lenne elgondolni azt hogy mind
egy kategórián belül sőt igen igen sőt
sokkal erősebb egy cég hogyha ha
mindenféle van abszolút abszolút csak
meg kell tanuljunk kommunikálni
egymással mert ugye nekem az
alapbeállításom az lenne hogy az én
saját kategóriám felt igényei szerint az
alapálláspont szerintem az hogy
alázatosak kell legyünk tehát rájöjjünk
arra hogy a mások erősségei azok igazi
kincsek számomra
igen igen és hogy hogy hogy tényleg ez
hogy tisztában ami ugye oan ismeret
tisztában legyek magammal azzal hogy
nekem hol vannak az erősségeim nekem
mire van igényem ugyanakkor nagyon hogy
te is mondtad figyeljek oda és legyek
alázatos annyira hogy hogy meglássam a
másikat meghallgassam a másikat és vele
le viszont az ő igényei szerint
kommunikáljak vagy mert hogy nem lesz
másképp hatékony kommunikáció hatékony
munka ha én én mind az én sávomon de
hogy a mi sávunk sehog n sem keresztezi
egymást mertogy nem nem így lett ez k
abszolút meg meg igazi katasztrófáktól
megmenthet emlékszem hogy a cégünknél
ugyanúgy elvégeztük ezt a tesztet és
most a big five-ról beszélek és kijött
egy pár munkatársamról hogy neurotikusak
kor már tudtam hogy kell figyelni a
neurotikusságra és az egyik munkatársam
aki amúgy magas neurotikusságba szólt
hogy figyeljünk oda mert a az anfnál b
bajaink lesznek hogyha bizonyos
papírokat nem intézünk el előre és
elején az első reakcióm az volt hogy nem
és utána aztán kezdtem gondolkozni erre
kell figyeljek mert biztos hogy valami
valamiért ő a a a szénbányákba a kanári
és szól szól szól nekünk és akkor akkor
gyakorlatilag utánaáártam ennek az
egésznek de nem győzök eléggé hálás
lenni hogy akkor csengetett és mint
érzékeny szenzor szólt hogy hogy
figyeljünk erre és ugyanígy egymásnak
tényleg a az áldása á tudunk válni az
erősségeinkkel mert én én tudom magamról
hogy például én egy egy egy piros vagyok
domináns személy vagyok de ennek a
hátulütője az az az hogy ha leuralok
másokat akkor gyakorlatilag nem lesz
addig fejlődik a cég ameddig az én
szintem tart hogyha képtelen vagyok
megengedni hogy mások is vezessenek és
mások is a kezdeményezést a kezükben sőt
nem is bátorítom őket akkor nem fog
fejlődni adott szint után a cégünk hát
meg meg ugye itt fontos hogyha te a
kanárit ledominálod akkor nem fog szólni
hogy igen
pontosan nem az esztétikát az örömöt a a
jó kedvet ezeket nem lehet dominanciával
kierőszakolni a másikból meg az
őszinteséget igen igen tényleg meg kell
tanuljuk kiaknázni a a a különbségekből
származó előnyöket meg meg kiegészíteni
egymást nem nem egy valami sablonra
vágyni amit mindenkire rá lehet húzni
mert hogy ez nem is nem is reális de
hogy hogy tényleg hatalmas erő van ebben
hogy mind hogy mind különbözők vagyunk
és mind mással tudunk hozzájárulni a
munkához és ezt tanítjuk a fiataloknak
is meg ezt engedjük nekik hogy
megtapasztalják a közösségi projektekben
például
úgy hogyha most össze kéne foglalni
amúgy még nem tervezem befejezni mert
van egy nagyon fontos téma amiről egy
kicsit szeretnék beszélgetni de ha most
össze kéne foglalni a hallgatók kedvéért
hogy miről is szól ez a leaders for all
én most magamnak úgy foglalnám össze
hogy ez az a hely ahol
önismeretet tanulhatnak
felelősségvállalásnak a fontosságát
tanulhatják meg történeteket hallanak és
azok a történetek mélyenmélyen
megpendítenek olyan húrokat amit lehet
hogy majd 10 20 30 év múlva is még
emlékezni fognak erre megtanulják a
csapatjátékot megtanulják a közösségnek
a megtartó erejét megtanulják azt hogy
hogy a felelősségvállalása az nem egy
opció nem egy nem egy jól hangzó valami
hanem abszolút egy egy szükséglete az
embernek úgyhogy a hallgatóknak a
szülőknek mindenképpen javaslom ezt a
programot hog jövőre küldjék a
gyermekeiket és a fiatalokat akik
hallják hogy jelentkezzenek mert mert
tényleg egy jó szórakozás és egy igazi
felemelő élmény én én csodálkoztam hogy
hogy ennyire sok hölgy vett részt rajta
és és gyanítom hogy pont amiatt mert az
a tévképzetünk van hogy a az önismeret
az az egy feminin dolog azt kell mondjam
hogy egyáltalán nem tehát it itt itt
arról van szó hogy harcosokat kell
képezzünk magunkból a gyermekeinkből is
ahhoz hogy valaki harcos legyen hogy
képes legyen nekivágni a felvenni a
keresztjét úgy ahogy beszéltük
oda önismeret kell alázat kell belső
fegyelem kell és ezek ezek ezekről mind
szó volt
így ahogy igen és hogy hogy még arra
gondolok hogy lehet hogy ezzel a harcos
szereppel nem tud mindenki azonosulni
mert ez egy erős
aktív létet kér de hogyha nem is harcos
de hogy legalább reziliens azt azt
szerintem szerintem mindannyian akarunk
hát faragni visszatérnék erre az
igehasználatra faragni a gyermekeinkbőlü
ühüm
igen és a ez amit mondtál te is erika
hogy nagyon nehezen tudtak azonosulni
vagy megijedtek attól hogy
domináns főként egyrészt azért is mert
hogy ugye ahogy te is mondtad inkább
lányok vannak a képzésen nagyrészt
lányok vannak és én így visszaemlékezve
csak lányoktól hallottam ezt a biztos
hogy fiúk között is volt olyan aki
akinek úgy nem jött természetesen hogy
azt mondja hogy á gyerekek én domináns
vagyok de a lányoknál még kevésbé azt
hiszem hogy és nem lehet általánosítani
mert soha nem lehet de én például a
saját példámból kiindulva én nem vagyok
domináns de hogyha ha valaki azt mondaná
mondjuk éön először csinálom meg a
diszket és azt mondják hogy réka te
domináns vagy akkor én azt hallanám hogy
én főnököskö én főnökösködő vagyok én én
túl sok vagyok igen igen holott nem nem
tudnám megmondani neked hogy ezt hol
szedtem össze abszolút meg meg az is van
hogy hogy valójában mindenki meg kell
tanuljon dominánsan viselkedni tehát nem
az tehát akármi is jön ki a nem
természetes közegedbe meg kell tanulj
navigálni tehát hogyha egy introvertált
személy vagy meg kell tanulj
extrovertált környezetben ami ha ha arra
van szükség hogy kiállj egy közönség elé
és elmondj valamit képes legyél vagy
csapatjátékos legyél vagy vagy összehoz
egy partit valakit összehoz embereket
han ez nem is a természetes közeget meg
kell tanulj attól még lehet hogy
introvertált sőt introvertált fogsz
maradni az egész életed során tehát az
mit jelent az introvertáls extrovertál
esetleg majd kijavíthatsz a végén azt
jelenti hogy hol pihensz meg ha csendben
pihensz meg akkor introvertát vagy ha az
emberek között pihensz meg akkor ex
vertált vagy ezen nem fogsz változtatni
én nem tudok változtatni én a csendben
pihenek meg viszont meg kell tanuljak
mint cégvezető beszélni az emberek előtt
és kezdeményezni és proaktív lenni és
előljárni és elfáradok úgy ahogy egy
podcast során is el szoktam fáradni
nagyon és utána szükségem lesz a csendre
de nagyon-nagyon élvezem a podcastet
amiatt mert igazi kincs ez egy sárkány
beszélgetünk és aztán annak a kincsét
elv legaláb három fejű ai esetünkben
igen igen
igen szóval hogy ez nagyon ezen mi is
ezen mi is gondolkodtunk többet meg nem
jutottunk igazából dűlőre de hogy hogy
igen hogy a lányok azok akik akik inkább
nem tudom komfortosabban mondják azt
hogy na akkor gyertek ezt csináljuk vagy
nem tudom mert tényleg nem jutottunk mi
sem eredményekre ezzel kapcsolatban h
nem csak ilyen
felismerésekig jutottunk egyelőre hogy
igen hogy érdekes hogy hogy ezt kell a
legtöbbet magyarázni hogy hogy ezzel
hogy tud komfortosan együtt élni az
ember ezzel a felismerésével hogy ő
domináns üüm igen
igen én én azt látom hogy a maszkulint
úgy lehet megfogni hogy elhívjuk amúgy a
feminint is záruljá be de abszolút egy
maszkulin narratíva egy történet az
amikor amikor elhívjuk hogy van egy
küldetésed gyere és és fogd meg ezt a a
nehézséget és és önként vállalva ennek
az archtipikus története az amikor az
atya elhívja a fiút hogy váltsa meg a
világot az a fiú amelyik el van hívva az
engedelmeskedik ez a gön
játék hogy ha engedetlen fiúk vannak
mindenhol akkor az az oka hogy nincsenek
elhíbva igazi
nehézségre és és azt látom hogy hogy a
másik üzenet pedig az hogy ne akarj
ártalmatlan lenni az ártalmatlanság az
nem egy
pozitívum hanem tanulj meg ártalmasnak
lenni de kontrolláld ezt az
ártalmasságot tehát sokkal jobb ha ha
ugyanaz amiről beszélgettünk a cinizmus
hogy sokkal jobb cinikusnak lenni mint
naívnak sokkal jobb ártalmasnak lenni
mint ártalmatlan nyuszinak lenni és azt
hiszem hogy ez is ez is az oka hogy a a
középiskolában mind azt tapasztaltam
hogy a a a szép lányok mind a a rossz
fiúkat kedvelték mert mert mert az van
hogy legalább képes ártani az a személy
nem nyuszi de ennél sokkal jobb hogyha
képes vagy ártani de mégsem teszed ühüm
igen és ez a képes vagy ártani de mégsem
teszed ez már visszakapcsol ehhez a ha
tudunk poklot teremteni tudunke menny
országot teremteni
valószínűleg ez már ez ez ez az
érettséggel kapcsol be az emberben ez a
funkció
hogy hogy az ember megszelííti a saját
ártásba figyelő képességit a saját
sárkányait igen amiért felelősséggel
tartozik miután megszelítette igen
miközben így beszéltél az fogalmazódott
meg bennem hogy egyrészt még van egy
csomó
kérdésem és nagyon élveztem veletek
beszélgetni tehát ez egy
kerekbeszélgetés volt és nagyon-nagyon
sok minden fontos dologról tudtunk
érintőlegesen egy kicsit beszélni v és
valamiről nem csak érintőlegesen én én
nagyon szívesen folytatnám tovább és
szerintem folytatni fogjuk ez az anyaság
kérdés ez egy nagyon fontos kérdés
számomra szeretnék egy kicsit mélyebben
belemenni majd és és sok sikert kívánok
nektek a leaders for allnak a
tevékenységeit
csak dicsérni tudom és hajrá
remélem hogy sok résztvevőtök lesz és
hogy egy alternatívát tudtok nyújtani
abszolút egy hiánycikk az amit adtok
úgyhogy köszönöm szépen hogy itt
voltatok és remélem megkapjuk a kellő
pillanatot amikor még egyszer érdemes
leüljünk és egyet beszélgessünk és
legyen egy szép napotok köszönjük szépen
kö köszönjük szépen ha tetszett ez a
műsor akkor iratkozz fel kérlek a
csatornánkra ezzel tudsz támogatni
minket köszönjük a vckker kávé közös a
jó kávéért az ötvösudvarnak a helyért
valamint a bizalomtőkének a támogatásért
nékületek nem jöhetett volna ez létre